so Halloween is just around the corner
and to celebrate in destiny Bungie has
created a new in-game event called the
festival of the Lost this is a
limited-time of bent that's going to run
until November the 9th heading to the
tower and you're going to notice some
things have changed you're going to
notice new decor sometimes maybe some
screams and your fellow Guardians
wearing some new masks to get your first
mask head on over to Eva levante she's
gonna have a legacy of the lost mystery
bag for you which is going to contain a
legendary mask there's roughly about 20
masks or show that you can acquire some
that are cooler than others she'll also
have some quests for you to do that
involve using the specific masks as well
as talking to different NPC's in the
tower as you make your way through the
tower to fill up that candy bag you're
actually going to notice that some of
these npcs have some fun new masks on
here you see the speaker he actually has
a traveller's mask on here is Lord
Shaq's wearing a tiger's mask and here's
Kade six trolling hairs with his own
eris morn mask you can acquire more
masks by filling up candy bags which you
can do by killing enemies or by pvp it
took me about three runs in the
exclusion zone to fill up one candy bag
once you've filled up a candy bag return
to evil avante to receive a rare masks
if you want to get masks faster and you
don't have the time to grind and farm
you can actually buy them at tests the
ever verse trading company has received
some new items for sale including the
legacy of the lost mystery bags which
you can buy in three different
variations one for 200 silver three four
five hundred silver and six four nine
hundred silver on top of that she has
three new emotes that you can purchase
the first of the three emotes is the
zombie dance which is very similar to
the thriller dance that one's 700 silver
the next is the monster dance and that
one's 500 silver and finally here's the
boom 0 which is 300 silver enjoy your
halloween and destiny tell me which mask
you like the most and which one you're
most likely going to wear in the
comments below stay tuned to gamespot
com for your continuing coverage of
destiny
you
[Music]